Now, is this decision problem in the set NP?
Well, remember that we need to show two things for it to be an NP--
it needs to have a short accepting certificate and it needs to have a fast verification algorithm.
In particular, what we don't need to do actually have a solution to this problem that's fast.
We just need to show that a certificate verification algorithm is fast.
So you should by now have a sense that the certificate in this case
is actually pretty straightforward.
If I tell you that there's a four clique in the graph, the way I can convince you that there's one there
is I give you the four nodes that make up the clique.
The verification algorithm then that you run is you go all the pairs of nodes in the certificate
and make sure that in the original graph G, they're actually connected.
So for each one, you should have to ask the question--okay, is this pair in edge in the graph,
is this pair in edge in the graph and that each of those tests takes unit time--constant time
and there's order Î˜ of kÂ˛ pairs to check, so this verification algorithm runs in polynomial time.
So just to drive this point home now, for every graph G that has a k clique,
there is a certificate that would cause the verification algorithm to say yes,
but for any graph G that doesn't have a k clique, there's no certificate
you can give it that would cause this verification algorithm to say yes.
And just to make certain here, the verification algorithm could also check
to see that the certificate that you gave it actually consist of k nodes.
Just to be careful.